ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BABIES
BACKER BOARD JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO QUARTET THE DALLY DODD
TORONTO EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERTZBERG WESTERN HER TADO
JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA
LIMÓN MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A CHOI BOGUE PAN
PORTANTINO. ROCK RUBIO SKI STERN
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WILK. MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG BY SENATOR EGGMAN
CENTER CABALLERO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SPIRIT OF GOD WE
LONG TO MEND A BROKEN CIRCLE.
THE HILL THE FRACTURES IN THE
WORLD AROUND US AND WITHIN OUR
OWN SOULS JUST TRANSFORM THOSE
PARTS OF OURSELVES THAT BLOCK
OUR CONTACT WITH OUR DEEPEST
REALITIES AND WITH THE DEEPEST
MOST SACRED DIMENSIONS OF ALL
OTHER BEINGS. BEARD OF GOD WE
LONG TO SEE REALITY. TO CONTACT
OUR DEEPEST YEARNING FOR A WORLD
PULSATING WITH JUSTICE AND
TRUTH. TO CREATE A SOCIETY WHERE
ALL SIT DOWN AT THE GREAT
BANQUET WHERE ALL PERSONS EAT
UNTIL THEY'RE FULL. SPIRIT OF
GOD WE LONG TO DISCOVER NEW THE
COURAGE DEEP WITHIN US TO SEE
AND TO LISTEN TO DISCOVER OUR
TRUE SELVES. TO TAKE STEPS TO
STOP THE CIRCLED THE CYCLES OF
VIOLENCE IN OUR HOMES IN OUR
WORKPLACES IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
IN OUR COUNTRY. AND IN OUR WHOLE
WORLD AMEN. READY BEGIN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS HAPPY THURSDAY
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ WE ARE MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. MEMBERS I KNOW YOU'RE
ALL HAPPY THURSDAY AS WELL BUT
LET'S- PENSION SO WE CAN GET OUR
BUSINESS DONE. INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING OF BILLS WE'RE
GOING TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SENATOR
BATES ARE YOU PREPARED. I DIDN'T
GET OUT ITEM NUMBER ONE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FOLLOW THE
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF STACY LOPEZ AS
DIRECTOR OF THE FOR THE DIVISION
OF ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES AND
KRISTEN MONTGOMERY AS DIRECTOR
OF ENTERPRISE INFORMATION
SERVICES AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT. OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION BOTH APPOINTEES
WERE APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS VOTE
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY SECOND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BATES MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING THEM MEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BASS I BAKER. FOR JUST BRADFORD HI.
CABALLERO I PROTECTING. FIVE
DALLY AYE DODD. THEY'RE AWESOME
I EGGMAN I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ HI
GROSS. HERTZBERG. WESTERN. HI
HER TADO HI JONES HI KAMLAGER.
HI LAYERED I LEYVA AYE LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ. MANY I NEWMAN
I NIELSEN I HAVE A TELEPHONE I
CAN. I PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE. WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WIENER. WILK HI. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS SO WE CAN
CONTINUE WITH THE BUSINESS OF
THE HOUSE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
FIVE ATKINS. BACKER I LARGEST.
DODD I GROVE HERTZBERG. I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE I'M%
BURKE AYE WIENER. IS THIRTY SIX
NOS ZERO. WE'LL WAIT A MOMENT
FOR EVERYONE TO GET SETTLED AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. CITING POINT
MINUTES CONFIRMED. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF THE FOLLOWING APPOINTEES TO
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
JACQUELYN HOSLER- ME SEE ON.
SAMANTHA MURRAY AND DR ERIC
BECAUSE OF A LETTER MISS HUSTLER
KARMI CND'S CHAIR OF THE
COMMISSIONS TRIBAL COMMITTEE
MISS MURRAY SERVES AS THE
COMMISSION'S VICE PRESIDENT IN
THIS CULTURE OF THE MARINE
RESOURCES COMMITTEE AND DOCTORS
OF ELEKTA IS THE CO CHAIR OF THE
WILDLIFE RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
THESE WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY SECOND ON
A FIVE ZERO VOTE I ASK FOR YOU
YOUR I. BUILT THE CENTER BATES
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
. SEEING AND HEARING THEN MEMBER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS.
BATES I BAKER FIVE PORCHES
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I FOR
TAXIS I DALY AYE DODD. I TORONTO
I EGGMAN. I GLAZER I GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. I
FURTADO I JONES HI KAMLAGER.
FIVE LAYERED FIVE LEYVA I LIMÓN
I MCGUIRE AYE MULLIN I MIN AYE
NEW AYE NIELSEN I A CELLO BOW
AYE PAN. I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
NUMBER HI WE CAN SKI I WIENER
AYE WILK. HI. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT. DO OF
ONE MORE TIME PLEASE GO THROUGH
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. ATKINS I FORGE'S
GROVE BY THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE TO
SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM THREE
SENATOR RUBIO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
SIXTY BY SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE
TO SPEED SAFETY AWARENESS MONTH
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT SR SIXTY A RESOLUTION
DECLARING THE MONTH OF FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY SB SAFETY
AWARENESS MONTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN I WAS A SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR PART OF MY JOB WAS
TO TAKE CARE THE TRAFFIC IN
FRONT OF OUR SCHOOL AND I SAW SO
MANY NEAR MISSES IN CHILDREN
AGES CROSTINI AND PARENTS- SCARE
FOR THE LIFE FOR THEIR CHILDREN
AS CARS WERE SPEEDING BY.
PARENTS AND CHILDREN ARE ALWAYS
TRYING TO DODGE THE CARS THAT
JUST WON'T STOP IN FRONT OF A
SCHOOL ONE YEAR A STUDENT WAS
HIT AND KILLED RIGHT OUTSIDE
ANOTHER SCHOOL THIS WAS SO
TRAUMATIZING ON ME TO THE
TEACHERS THE PARENTS BUT TO THE
APPARENT IN PARTICULAR WHO WAS
DISABLED WHO IS A SINGLE MOTHER
AND RELIED ON THAT CHILD FOR SO
MANY THINGS OF COURSE SHE NEVER
RECOVERED AND HER LIFE WAS
ALTERED AND CHANGED. AND TOP.
AND I THINK OF THAT MOTHER OFTEN
. TRAGEDIES LIKE THE JUST HAVE
TO. IF ONLY WE CAN EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF DRIVING THE SPEED
LIMIT UNFORTUNATELY SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC WE
HAVE SEEN A DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
DANGEROUS DRIVING AND SPEEDING
OF CARS. ACCORDING TO DATA FROM
THE C. H. P. THE NUMBER OF
DRIVERS SPEEDING OVER ONE
HUNDRED MILES PER HOURS. ON OUR
HIGHWAYS NEARLY DOUBLED BETWEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY. THAT IS SIGNIFICANT. AND
LIVES ARE AT STAKE AND IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES A RECENT STUDY
ALSO SHOWED THAT NEARLY 50% OF
DRIVERS DROVE. ELEVEN MILES PER
HOUR OR HIGHER ABOVE THE SPEED
LIMIT AROUND SCHOOL ZONES IN
PARTICULAR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE TODAY IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS RESOLUTION. LIVES ARE AT
STAKE LIVES ARE ALTERED AND
SOMETIMES HAVE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS FROM GENERATIONS TO
GENERATIONS. THIS IS WHY I
INTRODUCED SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE LAST YEAR TO
INCREASE THE ENFORCEMENT OF
SPEED LIMITS AROUND SCHOOL
ZONES. AND THAT IS WHY I AM
PRESENTING SR TODAY. S. R. SIXTY
TODAY TO ENCOURAGE EFFORTS THAT
REDUCING SPEED. AND TO INCREASE
AWARENESS OF THIS MAJOR PROBLEM
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NINE MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SIX ALSO SENATOR RUBIO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR RUBIO
RELATIVE TO TEEN DATING VIOLENCE
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION MONTH.
CENTER RUBIO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PROBABLY PRESENT F. YOU'RE A
SIXTY FIVE WHICH PUT PROCLAIMS
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY AS TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH AND THAT IS WHY
TODAY I'M ALSO WEARING ORANGE.
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT ISSUE THE
MONTH OF FEBRUARY CALLS UPON
CALIFORNIANS TO OBSERVE THIS
MONTH WITH PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES THAT RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT THE DYNAMIC FIFTEEN DATING
VIOLENCE AND PREVENTION. WE MUST
TEACH HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP
SKILLS THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS
THAT ENSURE A POSITIVE AND SAFE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
TEENS THIS ISSUE DOES NOT ONLY
AFFECT TEENS BUT EVERYONE THEIR
PARENTS THEIR TEACHERS THEIR
NEIGHBORS AND OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PREVENTION. CONTINUES TO BE A
CRITICAL INVESTMENT. THE WE SET
ACTIVELY ADDRESS WE CAN AND MUST
DO BETTER TO PREVENT FUTURE
VIOLENCE AND SUPPORT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN FORMING HEALTHY AND
SAFE RELATIONSHIPS WE ALSO NEED
TO CHANGE THE MINDSET. AND START
THINKING DIFFERENTLY TO ALL
PARENTS AND FAMILIES OUT THERE I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO NOT ONLY ASK.
IS THERE VIOLENCE IN YOUR
RELATIONSHIP ARE YOU BEING
ASSAULTED PUT ARE YOU BEING
COERCED AS WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
EQUALLY IMPORTANT AND THAT IS
THE ABILITY TO TAKE SOMEONE'S
FREE WILL. TO FREELY CHOOSE
THEIR FRIENDS TAX MESSAGE HANG
OUT WITH THEIR FAMILY AND THAT
IS UNACCEPTABLE THAT IS JUST AS
BAD AS THE PHYSICAL ABUSE. WE
MUST ALSO ENSURE THAT OUR TEAMS
ARE NOT IMMERSED IN A TOXIC
CULTURE THAT NORMALIZES VIOLENCE
OR COERCION BUT INSTEAD WORKS TO
UPLIFT THOSE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED VIOLENCE SO THAT
THEY MAY HEAL. AND MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT FEAR I WANT TO THANK THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TWENTY
MYSTIC VIOLENCE FOR SPONSORING
THIS RESOLUTION AND OF COURSE
ALL MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES FOR
PART THREE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR MEN
. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS A
PROUD MEMBER OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HI RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
SIXTY FIVE. RECOGNIZING THE
MONTH OF FEBRUARY IS THE TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH. AND I'M PROUD
TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
AND I COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BALDWIN PARK FOR OFFERING THIS.
WE KNOW THE VIOLENCE AND TEEN
DATING IS FAR TOO OFTEN. AND
HAPPENS FAR TOO OFTEN IN RECENT
STUDY DONE ON HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THE CDC FOUND IN THAT
IN THE PAST YEAR NEARLY ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAD EXPERIENCED
PHYSICAL HARM FROM SOME OF THE
ROMANTICALLY INVOLVED WITH. OF
THIS POPULATION YOUNG GIRLS AND
MOST ROLE BOUGHNER BOWL WITH ONE
IN THREE GIRLS IN UNITED STATES
REPORTING SOME KIND OF PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL OR VERBAL ABUSE IN A
RELATIONSHIP. WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THE SEVERITY OF TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE BECAUSE IT IS
THE GATEWAY TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IT'S THE GATEWAY TO DEPRESSED
INCOME. TO DEPRESSION TO ALL
SORTS OF HARMS IN THE FUTURE OF
THESE YOUNG WOMEN AND IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT WE AS A STATE A
PROGRESSIVE STATE LEADS CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE PROTECTIONS AND
REMEDIES FOR SURVIVORS SOUGHT
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MEN CENTRO VOGUE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
S. C. R. SIXTY FIVE TEEN DATING
VIOLENCE IS A PROMINENT ISSUE
THAT AFFECTS OUR CHILDREN AND
THEIR PARENTS FRIENDS TEACHERS
AND COMMUNITIES IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE NOT ONLY SHINE A LIGHT
ON THESE ISSUES BUT ALSO DO
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWERS
LEGISLATORS TO BREAK THE CYCLE
OF VIOLENCE. CHILDREN WHO ARE
SURVIVORS OF VIOLENCE OR WITNESS
TO VIOLENCE KERRY THOSE
EXPERIENCES WITH THEM FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES THE FIRST
STEP TO BREAKING THE CYCLE IS TO
ENSURE THAT SURVIVORS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE PROVIDED WITH
SUPPORT. WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THAT IS WHY IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA. WHICH
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL LIFESAVING SERVICES TO
SURVIVORS THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES. THERE ALSO
REMAINS A GREAT NEED FOR
PREVENTATIVE EDUCATION AND
INCREASING PUBLIC AWARENESS
AROUND THE PREVALENCE OF TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE WE ALL PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN AMPLIFYING THE
VOICES OF SURVIVORS AND PUTTING
AN END TO THIS VIOLENCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU SENATOR OTOBO SEE NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THOSE COMMENTS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
RUBIO MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW ABOUT TO MOVE
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO PULL
ANYTHING OFF OF CONSENT PRIOR TO
THAT CENTER CALM WATER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE
TO REMOVE FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
IS A C. R. ONE OH FOUR. THANK
YOU CENTER COM WATERED THE DESK
WILL NOTE. MENDOZA ANYTHING ELSE
. SEEING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION. TWENTY NINE FORTY
FOUR NINETY THREE NINETY SIX
NINETY NINE ONE HUNDRED ONE OH
TWO ONE OF 310-511-1117 AND
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE TWENTY. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BACKER AYE FORTUS
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
PROTECTING AYE DOLLY AYE DODD. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. FIVE FURTADO FIVE JONES
HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA HI
LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE. HI MELENDEZ
AYE MEN AYE NEWMAN. NIELSEN HI
PATROL BOAT HI PAM FIVE
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE NUMBER I
LIKE HOW SKI I WIENER. FIVE WILK
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. PORGES GROVE NEWMAN.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
BE MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THURMOND IS FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT PURSUED SENATE RULE
TWENTY EIGHT I MAKING A MOTION
TO REMOVE THIS YEAR FIVE FROM
THE SENATE GEO COMMITTEE AND
BROUGHT TO THE FLOOR. S. C. R.
FIVE WOULD END THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY DECLARED BY THE
GOVERNOR THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
THAT IS BECAUSE ONE THIRD OF OUR
RESTAURANTS TO CLOSE PERMANENTLY
SHOULD BE RECONSIDERED AND
DEBATED OUT OF RESPECT TO THE
RESTAURANT OWNERS WHO'VE LOST
THEIR LIVELIHOOD IT SHOULD BE
DEBATED BECAUSE OF THE CDC
REPORT EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS FOR
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS AMONG KIDS
JUMPED 31% IN TWENTY TWENTY.
ESSERE FIVE SHOULD BE HEARD
BECAUSE MORE THAN NINETY THREE
THOUSAND DRUG OVERDOSE CENTER
MELINDA'S YES WE KNOW YOU WANT
TO BE HEARD SO WE DON'T NEED TO
DEBATE THE RESOLUTION WELL I'M
NOT DEBATING RESOLUTIONS AND
GIVING THE REASONS AS TO WHY WE
SHOULD HAVE THIS BILL WOULD RIDE
HAILING HERE'S YOUR DEBATING
THAT RESOLUTION SO YOU WOULD
LIKE IT TO BE HEARD WE
UNDERSTAND WHY I'D LIKE TO MAKE
A MOTION TO- FOR YOUR FOR PEOPLE
TO VOTE. I DO AND 'D LIKE TO
MAKE THE CASE AS TO WHY THIS
MOTION SHOULD BE HEARD BECAUSE
WE HAVE DONE THIS DRILL SEVERAL
TIMES UNSUCCESSFULLY SHOWING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE POINT IS
DRIVEN HOME AS TO WHY WE
UNDERSTAND THE POINT AND THEN
AND I LET HIM AND I LET YOU
PROCEED THROUGH. THREE OF YOUR
POINTS SO I THINK WE UNDERSTAND.
SO IS THAT. YOU'RE DONE THE ROLE
THREE YOU GET TO MAKE THREE
POINTS. I REALLY DON'T TO MAKE
ANY POINTS I WAS GIVING YOU SOME
DIFFERENCE- I DON'T GET TO MAKE
ANY POINTS OKAY I SEE. WELL I
WILL MAKE THE POINT THAT THIS
BODY NEEDS TO STAND UP TO THE
GOVERNOR IN STAND UP FOR THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. AND PASS THIS YEAR
BY THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
MELINDA'S CONCERNED REQUIRE FOR
A PURPOSE YOU RISE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NO VOTE THANK YOU THE
MAJORITY LEADER IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE SENATOR MELINDA THIS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE YES
SENATOR JONES. YOU THINK ABOUT
PRESIDENT JUST ONE ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MOTION. AND
ENCOURAGE THE BODY TO WITHDRAW
SCR FIVE FROM COMMITTEE. AS WE
ARE SEEING IN THE NEWS EVEN
THOUGH YOU. HOUSE IN CANADA BY
MINISTER JOE IS COMING ON TO THE
HOUSE OF COMMONS TO DEBATE WITH
THE MINORITY LEADERS. ON THE
PURPOSE OF THE- ACTION SO I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SENT JOHN
MADISON. PLEASE CALL ROLL. ALLEN
NO ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO BATES
. HI BAKER. NO PORCHES. BRADFORD
NO CABALLERO NO PROTECTING NO
DALLY I DODD NO DERON. NO EGGMAN
. NO GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ NO
GROWTH. HERTZBERG NO WESTERN NO
TADO NO JONES HI KAMLAGER NO
LAYERED NO LEYVA NO LIMÓN NO
MCGUIRE. NO MELENDEZ FIVE MEN NO
NEWMAN NO NIELSEN I- TELEVOTE I
PAN. NO PORTANTINO. NO ROTH. NO
RUBIO. NO SKINNER. NO STERN. NO
NUMBER I- NO NUMBER NUMBER NO
WAY CASKEY NO RIGHT WIENER NO
WILK HI. NO SEVEN ARE EXCUSE ME
BUYS SAID NOES THREE ONE THE
MOST FOR MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO COMMIT ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
EGGMAN. BUDGET SUB THREE WILL
START AT. THE CONCLUSION OF
SESSION NINE FORTY FIVE IN ROOM
. TWO OR THREE. FOR TWO OR THREE
I'M GOING TO BE A TURN IN THE.
BUDGET SUB THREE IN ROOM AT
FORTY TWO OH THREE. VERY GOOD
ANYONE ELSE THING NO ONE ELSE
WE'RE GOING TO RETURN TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TO CHURN AT DOING A
GERMAN THE MEMORY. ARE YOU
GETTING JOINT CENTER LEVEL. I
YES ACTUALLY BETTER THAT SPECIAL
NOTE HERE SENATOR LEYVA. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS IT
IS WITH GREAT SADNESS AT THAT I
ASKED WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY TODAY
IN THE MEMORY OF AND WOOD
PICHLER WHO PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND THE YOUNGEST OF
FIVE IS BORN IN POMONA
CALIFORNIA ON MARCH TWENTY
FOURTH NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE HER
FAMILY INCLUDING HER BROTHERS
RICK DOUG STEVEN AND CAROL CARL
LOVED AND ADORED HER. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT AND LOVE TO DO WAS
SWIM SHE ACTUALLY LOVES SWIMMING
SO MUCH THAT ONE SUMMER HER
BLONDE HAIR EVEN TURNED GREEN.
OF COURSE THAT DID NOT STOP HER
FROM JUMPING IN THE POOL AND
DIVING UNDER THE WATER SO THAT
SHE COULDN'T HEAR HER MOM AND
DAD WHEN THEY WERE CALLING HER
TO COME INTO THE HOUSE. AND ALSO
LEARN TO KNIT AND CROCHET FROM
HER MOM. SHE LOVED TO KNIT GIVES
WITH THE MOST INTRICATE DESIGNS
AND SPENT HOURS AND DAYS
KNITTING BEAUTIFUL BLANKETS
SCARVES HATS AND BABY BOOTIES
FOR SPECIAL OCCASIONS. AND
LITTLE LIFE OF LOVE COURAGE AND
KINDNESS AND SHOWED HER FAMILY
AND LOVED ONES UNCONDITIONAL
LOVE THROUGH HER ACTIONS AND
KIND WORDS. SHE WAS OUT THE MOST
LOVING TEXT MESSAGES THAT TOLD
YOU HOW MUCH SHE LOVES YOU WAS
PROUD OF YOU AND THAT SHE WAS
BLESSED TO HAVE YOU IN HER LIFE.
SHE WOULD MAKE YOUR BED MAKE
YOUR BAD DAY INTO A DAY WHERE
YOU COULD FEEL HER LOVING ARMS
HUG YOU SO DEEPLY. THAT ALL OF
YOUR WORRIES JUST MELTED AWAY.
AND REYES THREE INTELLIGENT
LOVING AND CARING CHILDREN OF
HER OWN. WHILE RAISING HER
CHILDREN SHE STILL FOUND TIME TO
VOLUNTEER AT THEIR SCHOOLS SHE
ACTUALLY LOVED VOLUNTEERING SO
MUCH ONE OF HER KIDS BELIEVE
THAT SHE ACTUALLY WORKED THERE
AS AN EMPLOYEE. HE RECENTLY
FOUND OUT THAT IT WAS ALL
VOLUNTEER TIME. AND TAUGHT HER
KIDS THE VALUE OF HARD WORK IN
EDUCATION AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
TO BE KIND AND LOVING. SHE ALSO
DEDICATED HER CAREER TO LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. SHE BEGAN AND
THE KILLER BE HOT LINE
DEPARTMENT AND THEN TEN YEARS
LATER WHILE RAISING HER THREE
CHILDREN SHE COMPLETED HER AA
AND DATABASE MANAGEMENT AND
EARNED HER POSITION AS EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY. WITH THE L. A. C.
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
COMMISSIONER WAIT A MEASURES FOR
NINETEEN YEARS. AND HAD RECENTLY
RETIRED LEFT POMONA AND MOVED TO
LAKE ISABELLA WITH HER HUSBAND
JOHN PICHLER AND THEIR FIVE FOR
BABIES. SO MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A JOINING TODAY IN THE
MEMORY OF AN AMAZING MOM.
GRANDMA WIFE SISTER DAUGHTER.
AUNT AND FRIEND. AND WOOD
PICHLER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FORWARD TO
THAT THE SENATE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED HER.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YES IN
YOUR GONNA PRESIDENT TURN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU ARM MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY. TO RECOGNIZE THE
LIFE AND THE LEGACY OF SOMEONE
MANY OF US HAVE A GREAT PLEASURE
OF WORKING WITH OVER THE YEARS
IN CALLING A FRIEND. MARTY
MORGANSTERN. SOME IN THIS ROOM
KNOW VERY WELL. MARTING WAS
NOTHING LESS THAN A FIXTURE
CALIFORNIA POLICY AND POLITICS
EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY HE WAS A
CHAMPION A FIGHTER FOR WORKING
CLASS CALIFORNIANS EVERY SINGLE
DAY OF HIS CAREER. WAS WHAT HE
WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT MEMBERS HE
ONCE TOLD WAREHOUSE WORKERS NO
ONE SHOULD HAVE TO MARCH FOR
FIFTY MILES FOR BASIC RIGHTS.
MARTY SPENT A LIFETIME WORKING
TO ENSURE THAT STATEMENT WAS
TRUE FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. HE MARCHED STORE
WORKERS WOULD BE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND TREATED WITH THE
RESPECT THAT THEY DESERVE. A
NATIVE NEW YORKER. MARTY WAS
RAISED IN THE BRONX. AND WAS THE
FIRST IN HIS FAMILY TO GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL THEN COLLEGE IS
ADVOCACY WORK FOR WORKERS
STARTED FROM A YOUNG AGE. HE
QUICKLY ROSE TO THE RANKS AND
WELFARE WORKER IN HARLEM TO
UNION LEADER AFTER LEADING A
STRIKE. THE NEW YORK CITY
WELFARE DEPARTMENT. HE MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TO BECOME THE STATE DIRECTOR OF
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY. AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
TWO YEARS LATER. HE MET
SECRETARY OF STATE. JERRY BROWN
. WHEN BROWN WAS ELECTED
GOVERNOR HE NAMED MARTY IS THE
STATE'S TOP LABOR NEGOTIATOR AT
THE STATE OFFICE OF EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS. MORNING THEN SERVED
GOVERNOR BROWN THE FIRST
GOVERNOR BROWN IS DIRECTOR. OF
THE SECOND GOVERNOR BROWN I
GUESS OF PERSONNEL
ADMINISTRATION EVENTUALLY CAME
BACK TO SACRAMENTO THE SERVER
THE SAME POSITION. FOR YOU
GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS. WHILE
SERVING GOVERNOR BROWN IN HIS
FIRST TWO TERMS MARTY HELPED THE
LANDMARK LEGISLATION IMPLEMENTED
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING FOR STATE
EMPLOYEES HUGE WIN. FOR THE
LABOR MOVEMENT IN CALIFORNIA AND
FOR THE NATION. IN THE LATE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES MARTY SERVICES
CHAIR OF THE CENTER FOR LABOR
RESEARCH EDUCATION UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY. WHEN JERRY
BROWN WAS ELECTED TO HIS THIRD
TERM IN TWO THOUSAND TEN MARTY
WAS BACK THIS TIME AS SECRETARY
OF LABOR. AND WORKFORCE. THE
SERVICE SECRETARY UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WHEN HE
RETIRED AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
YEARS. IT WASN'T THAT WASN'T ALL
FOR MARTY HE SERVED ON THE BOARD
OF COVERED CALIFORNIA NINETEEN
FIFTY A TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND
ONCE AGAIN WORKED TO BETTER OUR
STATE. GIVEN HIS EXTENSIVE
SERVICE TO THE STATE. IT SHOULD
BE NO SURPRISE THAT GOVERNOR
BROWN RECOGNIZE MARTY BY
PROCLAIMING NOVEMBER NINTH. TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN IS MARTY
MORGANSTERN DAY. TO SCORE MARTY
WAS ABOUT BRINGING TWO SIDES
TOGETHER IN STRIKING A DEAL THIS
MANTRA. NEGOTIATE NEGOTIATE
NEGOTIATE EVEN SERVING AS A TOP
LEVEL OF STATE GOVERNMENTS AND
HAVING AN EAR TO THE GOVERNOR HE
NEVER LOST SIGHT. OF WHO IS
FIGHTING FOR THE LITTLE GUY. OUR
STATE IS BETTER WHEN SERVED. IT
SERVES A LITTLE GUY IT'S WITH
MARTY WAS ALL ABOUT THAT'S WE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY WE CELEBRATE
HIS LIFE A LIFE OF A MAN WHO
MARCHED EVERY DAY TO POWER
WORKERS MARTY SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE SYLVIA HIS DAUGHTER CHOI.
AND HER WIFE AMY AND THEIR
GRANDDAUGHTER INDIGO. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE A MOMENT AND JOINING
IN ENSURING THE MEMORY OF THE
GREAT MARTY MARKET STREET THANK
YOU CENTER HERTZBERG SAID
EARLIER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TRUMP IT WAS MY HONOR
AND MY PLEASURE TO SERVE WITH
MARTY IN THE CABINET AND HE WAS
EVERYTHING THAT WAS JUST SAID.
HE WAS A JOY A GENERALLY WHEN
THERE WAS A CRISIS HE WOULD
START LAUGHING RIGHT BEFORE HE
WOULD GO AND BRING EVERYBODY
TOGETHER AND SOLVE THE PROBLEM
WITH HIS COMMITMENT TO WORKING
PEOPLE IN MIND. BUT I CAN'T SAY
IT BETTER THAN A MESSAGE I HAVE
FROM FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
AND I WOULD ASK FOR PERMISSION
TO READ. PERMISSION GRANTED. I
FIRST MET MARTY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE IN A JAPANESE
RESTAURANT IN SACRAMENTO. HE WAS
TALKING IN A VERY LOUD VOICE A
FEW TABLES AWAY. I HAD BRIEFLY
ENCOUNTERED MARTY DURING A
MEETING WITH CSEA AND WAS
IMPRESSED WITH HOW HE HANDLED
HIMSELF. SO I WENT OVER TO HIM
AND SAID HE SHOULD COME TO WORK
FOR ME. WHICH HE SOON DID. IN NO
TIME MARTY HAD SET UP THE FIRST
OFFICE OF EMPLYEE RELATIONS. IT
WORKED GREAT AND HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN SOLVING
COUNTLESS EMPLOYEE ISSUES.
ALWAYS QUICK BUT VERY FAIR.
EVERYBODY TRUSTED HIM. MARTY WAS
TRULY UNUSUAL FORCEFUL WEISS.
AND A GREAT FRIEND. I JOIN IN
ADJOURNING IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU CENTER LAYERED CENTER
TORONTO YES I WANT TO THANK THE-
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THIS AGENDA MEMORY. I
MET MR MORGANSTERN WHEN I WAS
HEAD OF THE L. A. FEDERATION OF
LABOR AND- I THOUGHT TO MYSELF
REALLY. SOMEBODY'S GONNA BE
BROUGHT OUT OF RETIREMENT TO
HEAD LABOR IN CALIFORNIA SUCH AN
IMPORTANT STATE IN THE WHOLE
COUNTRY- AND WHEN I MET HIM AND
THE TIME THAT I SPENT WITH HIM-
WAS JUST EXTRAORDINARY. SUCH A
SMART FUNNY DOWN TO EARTH PERSON
I HAD NEVER MET IN THAT KIND OF
A POSITION SO- IBM I GREW TO
MISS HIM AFTER HE ACTUALLY DID
RETIRE AND- I JUST APPRECIATE SO
MUCH WHAT HE DID FOR WORKING
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
SENATOR DORADO THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG PLEASE BE SURE TO
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
CYLINDER TORONTO I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE IN THE JOURNEY MEMORY. YES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
RISE TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF FORMER US
REPRESENTATIVE ESTEBAN SOLIS WHO
PASSED AWAY LATE LAST MONTH AT
THE AGE OF NINETY ONE. MISTER
TORRES WAS BORN IN ARIZONA WHERE
HIS FATHER WORKED IN THE COPPER
MINES. HIS FATHER WAS DEPORTED
ALONG WITH ONE MILLION OTHER
PEOPLE OF MEXICAN DESCENT.
DURING THE MEXICAN REPATRIATION
PROGRAM WHICH SWEPT UP CITIZENS
ALONGSIDE NON CITIZENS. THIS
FAMILY DRAMA WITH THE START
MISTER DORIS COMMITMENT TO THE
IMMIGRANT AND LATINO COMMUNITY
AND ALL AMERICANS. HIS MOTHER
THEN MOVED TO LA WHERE HE GREW
UP. WE WENT TO SCHOOL HIGH
SCHOOL IN EAST LA HE ENLISTED IN
THE ARMY AND SERVED IN THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS DURING THE
KOREAN WAR. WHEN HE BECAME
RETURNED. HE GOT A JOB AT THE
CHRYSLER PLANT IN MAY WOULD. HE
QUICKLY WAS ELECTED SHOP STEWARD
FOR THE UNION HE ROSE TO HOLD
SEVERAL LEADERSHIP ROLES IN THE
UNITED AUTO WORKERS UNION BOTH.
CALIFORNIA NATIONALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY. HE WAS
RECOGNIZED AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
ONE APPOINTED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY PRESIDENT
CARTER TO SERVE AS THE U. S.
REPRESENTATIVE TO UNESCO. AND
ALSO AS A WHITE HOUSE SPECIAL
ASSISTANT FOR HISPANIC AFFAIRS.
HE- I WAS ELECTED TO REPRESENT
HIS OWN COMMUNITY OF EAST LA IN
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
EVENTUALLY SERVING A TOTAL OF
EIGHT TERMS IN HIS TIME ON
CAPITOL HILL AMONG HIS
ACHIEVEMENTS MISTER DORIS-
INSURED LOW INCOME VICTIMS OF
NATIONAL NATURAL DISASTERS
RECEIVE FULL FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
A PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP FOR TWO
MILLION PEOPLE HE CHAIRED THE
HISPANIC CAUCUS CONGRESSIONAL
HISPANIC CAUCUS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS HE WENT ON TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. IS A VISITING
PROFESSOR AT WHITTIER COLLEGE
AND UCLA HE ALSO DID IS
DEDICATED HIS TIME TO THE ARTS
WHERE HIS WORK WAS DISPLAYED AT
GALLERIES THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES
AND ONE OF HIS LAST
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WAS COPE WITH
FOUNDER OF THE LAPLACE OPTICAL
DO THAT YET THIS MUSEUM IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES PERSONALLY
HE INSPIRED ME TO SEE THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN OUR COMMUNITY
NEEDS A GOOD UNION JOBS HOW
POLICY CAN WORK IN TANDEM WITH
GOVERNMENT TO CREATE A STRONG
MIDDLE CLASS. IT WAS EASY FOR
HIM TO BECOME A UNION LEADER YOU
SEE FROM THE CONDITIONS THAT IS
FAMILY FACED WHEN HIS FATHER
WORKED IN THE COPPER MINES TO
GOING TO A GOOD PAYING JOB WITH
ENFORCEABLE RIGHTS AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS IT WAS AN
EASY CONNECTION FOR HIM HE
TAUGHT OUR GENERATION SO MUCH
HIS GENERATION LED THE WAY FOR
LATE FOR OTHERS TO BE LEADERS ON
THE SHOP FLOOR AND TO RISE TO
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL FAME
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE RC.
FIVE CHILDREN TWELVE
GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN OUR DEEPEST
CONSOLE GUNNED CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY HIS LOVED ONES
ALTHOUGH IT IS NOT WITH US
PHYSICALLY AS CONTRIBUTIONS
WOMAN MADE OUR NATION STATE AND
COMMUNITY A BETTER PLACE. MAY
OUR BROTHER REST IN POWER. THANK
YOU SENATOR. SENATOR THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE IT IS WITH A HEAVY HEART
TODAY THAT I JOIN IN MEMORY OF
THE HONORABLE CONGRESSMAN UNION
LEADER TEACHER ACTIVISTS FROM
WEST COVINA ESTEBAN TORRES MR
TAURUS BEEN A LIFE DEDICATED TO
SERVICE AND HIS COMMUNITY. I
ADMIRED HIM VERY MUCH AND I SAW
SO MANY SIMILARITIES IN BOTH OF
OUR EXPERIENCES BORN TO A COPPER
MINER IN MIAMI ARIZONA IN
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE TAURUSES
FATHER WAS DEPORTED WHERE HE WAS
JUST WHEN HE WAS JUST A TODDLER
MR TAURUSES MR TAURUS SHARE THE
SAME HEART BROKE. BREAK IN
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE THAT MANY
FAMILIES ARE STILL EXPERIENCING
TODAY. AND THAT HIS FATHER WAS
DEPORTED TO MEXICO. AND SADLY
NEVER SAW HIM AGAIN. HE LATER
MOVED TO EAST LOS ANGELES WITH A
SINGLE MOTHER GREEN AYE GOMEZ
GRADUATED FROM GARFIELD HIGH
SCHOOL BEFORE ENLISTING AND
SERVING IN THE U. S. ARMY. UPON
RETURNING FROM HIS MILITARY TOUR
HE WAS AN ASSEMBLY LINE WORKER
ATCHRYSLER WHICH ALLOWED HIM TO
BECOME ACTIVE WITH THE UNITED
AUTO WORKERS UNION. CLIMBING THE
RANKS HE WAS THE UNION'S
INTERNATIONAL REPRESENTATIVE IN
WASHINGTON DC FROM. NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR TO NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. LATER THAT YEAR TORRAS
FOUNDER THAT TELUGU. FOUNDATION
A COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATIONS AS ITS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR UNTIL NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. HELICAL HAS ASSISTED AND
GIVEN OPPORTUNITIES TO THOUSANDS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO OTHERWISE
WOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. STABLE HOUSING AND
EVEN FOOD ACCESS IN THE SAME
YEAR- VALLEY AND THE LOS ANGELES
AREA. I HAD THE HONOR TO BE
RECOGNIZED BY TELUGU. AND ALSO
MANY PROUD SCHOLARS FROM THE
TELUGU FOUNDATION WHO WENT ON TO
DO EXTRAORDINARY THINGS. THE
LASTING IMPACTS OF HIS
ORGANIZATION ALONE ARE
COMPOUNDING BUT THIS WAS JUST
THE START TO MR TAURUSES LASTING
LEGACY. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN HE WAS APPOINTED.
PRESIDENT CARTER'S
ADMINISTRATION AS THE US
AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED NATIONS
EDUCATIONAL SCIENTIFIC AND
CULTURAL ORGANIZATIONS BEFORE
RETURNING TO CALIFORNIA. TO BE
ELECTED TO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES TO THE TO THE
THIRTY FOURTH. DISTRICT AND
NINETY TWO AS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS HAS ADVOCACY FOR THOSE
THAT WERE DISENFRANCHISED
CONTINUED HE WOULD ENSURE
MEMBERS OF THE ARMED FORCES WERE
GETTING THE BENEFITS THEY WERE
OWED AND METALS THEY WERE DUE.
AND AS A MEMBER OF A MILITARY
FAMILY WE CANNOT THANK HIM
ENOUGH TO TAKING THOSE STEPS TO
HONOR THOSE FARM FORCED MEMBERS.
HE FOCUSED ON ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES THAT AFFECTED OUR
REGION FROM POLLUTED WATER
TICKET TABLES TO GROUNDWATER TO
THE BKK LANDFILL CONTAMINATION
IN MY DISTRICT HE WAS NOT AFRAID
TO GET IN THE MIX WITH THESE
DIFFICULT ISSUES AND SERVE WITH. FOR MORE PRESSING ISSUES AND
CHALLENGES NO MATTER WHAT HE DID
WHETHER AS A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
LABOUR LEADER WHITE HOUSE
ASSISTANT OR MEMBER OF CONGRESS
HE WAS ALWAYS READY TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE WITH PATIENCE COMPASSION
AND WITH HIS WHOLE HEART. TORRES
WAS A LIFELONG FIGHTER FOR THE
COMMON GOOD AND FORGED A CAREER
PATH PUBLIC SERVICE THAT
INSPIRED SO MANY INCLUDING MY
OWN. I HAD THE HONOR OF MEETING
HIM EARLY IN MY PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER. AND HIS WEALTH OF
KNOWLEDGE PROBLEM SOLVING SKILLS
AND HIS ABILITY TO GET THE JOB
DONE WAS UNIQUE HE LEAVES A
LASTING LEGACY AND FOOTPRINT
THAT CANNOT BE FILLED AND THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING TO BE
PROUD OF. TAURUS IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE RC AND THEIR CHILDREN
CARMEN RE NOT CAMILLE SALENA AND
STEVE AND HIS MANY GRANDCHILDREN
SENATE COLLEAGUES PLEASE I ASK
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN A TURNING IN
HIS MEMORY. THE MEMBER OF
CONGRESS MAN ESTEBAN TORRES A
LOVING FATHER DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANT AN HONORABLE MAN HE WILL
BE MISSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER RUBIO SENATOR HERTZBERG.
WANT TO JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE JOURNEYING IN THE MEMORY
OF. CONGRESSMAN TAURUS- YOU KNOW
BACK IN THE DAY WHEN I STARTED
IN THIS BUSINESS THE- WE ONLY
HAD ONE CONGRESSMAN CONGRESSMAN
ROYBAL RECALLED IN THE
CONGRESSMAN. AND ALONG CAME A
SEVEN- WE CALLED M. ET THAT WAS
HIS NICKNAME ALL OF HIS FRIENDS
WE CALL THEM ET EN. I GETS WILL
SPEND THE TIME WITH THEM YOU
HEARD ABOUT HIS BACKGROUND
SERVICES WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
AND CONGRESS AND TELUGU IN THE
LIGHT. BUT WHAT'S INTERESTING
WHAT I EXPERIENCED AS YOUNG
PERSON WITH HIM. WHAT IS GRACE
WAS HIS DEMEANOR WAS HIS
TEMPERAMENT THAT SOMEBODY COULD
BE A FIGHTER FOR JUSTICE AND NOT
HAVE AN AGE TO BE ABLE TO BE AS
IMPACTFUL AS HE WAS I SPENT A
LOT OF TIME JAMIE KASO SON IN
LAW. WAS CHIEF OF STAFF IS ONE
OF MY BEST FRIENDS WHO JUST WAS
WITH HIM AND GARMIN RECENTLY AT
MY FRIENDLY THAT WAS WITH HIS
HOUSE AND- YOU KNOW TALKING
STORIES HE STILL WAS OKAY AT THE
TIME YOU STEPH PAT CAME AS A
GREAT SHOCK. AS MENTIONED HE WAS
A GREAT ARTIST THE END OF HIS
CAREER HE- GLORIA MOLINA PUT HIM
ON AS A CO FOUNDER OF THE-
CLASSICAL TO. THE I. T. ARTISTS
IN NOTE. LOS ANGELES ONE OF HIS
PASSIONS THAT HE MARRIED BOTH
HIS FIGHT. FOR JUSTICE ON THE
ONE HAND YET EIGHT EXTRAORDINARY
DELICATE HAND. IN ART. YOU KNOW
AND LIKE THESE INSURANCE BECAUSE
IT MEANS MY FRIENDS ARE GONE BUT
WHAT IT DOES MEAN IS IT GIVES US
ON THIS IMPORTANT SENATE FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO RECOGNIZE PEOPLE
THAT WERE EXTRAORDINARY IT MADE
BIG CONTRIBUTIONS ON WHOSE
SHOULDERS WE ALL STAND. ET WAS
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE C. WILL
MISS SOME. EVERYBODY WHAT A
GREAT ASSET YOU JANICE MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
CENTER ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
MEMORY ESTEBAN TORRES BACHELOR.
GROSSMAN REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
PEOPLE. BUT I ALSO RISE IS THE
CHAIR OF MILITARY VETERANS
COMMITTEE TO SAY WE'VE LOST
ANOTHER VETERAN A TRUE VETERAN
REPRESENTED VETERANS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
NATION ANY OPPORTUNITY TO STAND
UP FOR BETTER AND BETTER RIGHTS
VETERANS BENEFITS HE WAS THERE.
THE SEVEN TAURUS WAS KNOWN FOR
THAT AND THE COMMUNITY AND
SPEAKING OF THE COMMUNITY MY OWN
CITY OF PICO RIVERA HIS FAVORITE
RESTAURANT THE DEL REY OFTEN
SEEN THERE WITH. FRIENDS AND
FAMILY- JUST A COUPLE MILES FROM
MY HOME TODAY AND AS HE IS
VISITED- THE COMMUNITIES OF
WHITTIER THAT HE SURE GROUP HERE
THAT HE SURE AND THE FACT THAT
HE WAS DE- THE INITIAL START. OF
TELUGU WHICH PROVIDED GOOD UNION
PAYING JOBS THAT ESTABLISHED IT
THIS PRIDE OF EAST LOS ANGELES
THAT'D GROUP THAT TELUGU ROSE TO
BE RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE TOP
FIFTY IN THE NATION A SPANISH
RUN HISPANIC OWNED AND IT WAS
BECAUSE OF HIS LEADERSHIP SO
TRULY A COMMUNITY MEMBER TRULY
ADMIRED AND WE WILL MISS HIM
DEARLY. I WILL MISS ANOTHER
VETERAN I HAD THE HONOR TO VISIT
WITH THEM MANY MANY TIMES- HIS
BROTHER IN LAW- WHICH ARE CITY
ATTORNEY HI I'M IT WAS OUR CITY
ATTORNEY JAMIE WAS WAS ALWAYS
THERE AND- IT WAS A FAMILY
AFFAIR IN THE COMMUNITY HE WAS
OPEN TO EVERYONE. WE WILL MISS
HIM WE WILL MISS HIS PRIDE AND
HONOR AND DIGNITY HAVE SERVICE
AND I KNOW THAT THE HIGH SCHOOL
IN EAST LOS ANGELES- NAMED AFTER
HIM WILL ALWAYS REGARD HIM AS
THE BEST OF THE BEST GARFIELD
HIGH SCHOOL REMEMBERS THEM EVERY
SINGLE YEAR WHEN THE GARFIELD
BROS ABOUT PLAYS THEY ALWAYS SAY
WE HAVEN'T SEVEN TAURUS IS AN
ALUMNI. WELL LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THIS. WE LOST A GOOD
AS AMERICAN WE LOST A GOOD
AMERICAN MAY HE REST IN PEACE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU CENTER ARCHULETA. CENTER
DRAWS A PLEASE FOR HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. MEMBERS IF THERE
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS SEEING NONE
. CENTER ATKINS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. MADAM PRESIDENT THANK SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR A
BUSY WEEK OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR VALENTINE'S DAY
MONDAY FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT TWO PM
THANK YU THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
PLACED WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT
TWO PM HAVE A GREAT REST TODAY
MEMBERS.